hi guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about how to burn
belly fat step-by-step now in a lot of
other videos I talk about specific parts
of weight loss how to burn fat all
different aspects in this video we're
going to put everything together okay
there's really three basic sections the
basics of what to do things to add the
speed up weight loss and things to avoid
to speed up weight loss okay so let's
talk about the basics first and some of
this might be just repetitive but if
you've never seen a video from me this
will be very helpful make notes and I'll
put videos down below for a lot of the
summaries of other videos that you can
get detailed information on each thing
because I've probably done videos on
each separate item basics two to three
meals a day okay you can start with
three meals and then we you want to go
to two you don't want to graze all day
because every time you eat you spike
this hormone that prevents weight loss
called insulin okay so eating in general
will stimulate that so we want minimum
three meals a day or maximum through
three wheels and three meals a day
minimum two meals a day so some people
go to two and I'll get more into that
when we get into this next part right
here which is no snacking so when you
have six meals a day or five meals a day
and they're small and they're spread out
or you're snacking between meals you're
going to spike insulin we don't want to
do that that's going to create a big
problem for you so removing the snacking
is vital very very important
it's called intermittent fasting okay
now right here I suggest you start with
three meals and then do that for a while
get into ketosis or fat-burning and then
go to two meals if you can do it unless
you can't do it because you're working
out hard and you need three meals a day
I would say it's 5050 if you're
sedentary you can get by with two meals
a day and you will lose some serious
weight in your midsection insulin is the
hormone that is responsible for the
midsection weight so three meals no
snacking okay far as protein three to
six ounces based on your size your
stress level you're gonna need a little
more protein you don't want to go too
much because too much protein
will stimulate insulin okay three to six
ounces per meal now if you're not hungry
for protein let's say for dinner then
don't eat it so but this is kind of an
average now next one seven cups of
veggies why because we need to flesh out
all this fat that's going to be coming
out to your liver all the fat through
the body has to go through the liver and
if you don't consume enough vegetables
you can end up with a fatty liver plus
vegetables give us the potassium we need
we need about forty seven hundred
milligrams that's a lot so that's about
seven to ten cups
very few people do that but you want to
consume the vegetable first and have a
huge salad and then a small amount of
protein now next one is no sugar this is
a given because sugar increases insulin
and also I'm talking about the hidden
sugars the breads pasta cereal crackers
discus waffles pancakes muffins alcohol
okay so we want to cut the sugar and
refined carbs out next one healthy fats
this is essential because when you
consume fat at the end of the meal that
allows you to go to the next meal
without being so hungry in craving and
starving that your blood Sugar's crash
so this basically allows you to do three
meals or two meals without being hungry
thereby not increasing insulin fat is
one of the only things that does not
increase insulin it's neutral so this is
safe if you're worried about calories I
put some links down below okay these are
the basics now if we want to speed
things up we can add some MCTS to the
diet that's like in coconut oil medium
chain triglycerides that will increase
fat burning next one is potassium why
because at the heart of weight loss we
want to avoid insulin and so most people
that can't lose weight have too much
insulin they have insulin resistance so
we want to fix that potassium is one of
the ways to do that you can consume all
these vegetables or even take it in some
supplement potassium citrate to actually
heal the the aberration or dysfunction
of insulin next thing is apple cider
vinegar why because the acid and up soda
vinegar called acetic acid
does improve the output of ink insulin
it reduces insulin it improves insulin
resistance it lowers your blood sugars
so it's very good for diabetics and take
this one in the morning one teaspoon
with glass water and one before bed or
four with your dinner if you have
digestive issues very important chromium
again you can find a supplement from ham
to help your blood Sugar's chromium is a
mineral that actually has been proven to
help insulin again keep it in check B
vitamins another key thing especially
vitamin b1 for regulating insulin
control and improving insulin resistance
nutritional yeast is your go-to okay
next one is high-intensity interval
training if you add high-intensity
full-body resistance training
you're gonna spike growth hormone and
you're gonna speed up weight loss the
key is short bursts of high-intensity
lots of rest okay again I'll put some
videos down below to get specifics on
that but this one is this will just this
is the icing on the cake okay next one
is more sleep adding more sleep why
because growth hormone is triggered when
you're sleeping and that is the primary
hormone that stimulates fat burning so
more sleep so if you could just take
another take a nap sleep in longer get
an extra hour of sleep that goes a long
way that's more important than
high-intensity interval training sleep
is the key okay now next one is recovery
making sure that if you are doing
high-intensity interval training that
you're recovering after you're not doing
it every day some people need to do it
every other day some people every third
day some people once a week depending on
how you feel when you work out you're
fairly broken down then you get your
overtraining
okay so recovery is essential if you're
exercising now let's take a look at what
you need to remove this is just as
important as this okay
remove any type of sleeping issues
insomnia vital why because you're not
going to lose weight if you're not
sleeping all right I put a video down
below of what to do if you're not
sleeping there's a lot of things you can
do it's mainly stress
loading if you're bloating let's say
you're consuming too much kale or too
much you know cruciferous vegetables
that you're not used to consuming and
then you're bloating that is going to
slow down weight loss so you're gonna
have to go back to the vegetables that
you can digest and maybe even steam some
until the bloating goes away
also people consume too many nuts that
can create bloating again we want to
eliminate anything that bloats you
sometimes adding more apple cider
vinegar or an acidifier for the stomach
will help it or even a bile salt your
hub also they'll put some links down
below for bloating okay menstrual cycle
issues if your cycle is two weeks out of
the month you're not going to lose
weight because the high levels of
estrogen estrogen blocks the thyroid
estrogen crates fat on the hips and the
thighs and we need to handle this cycle
so it's really smooth again I put a link
down below of what to do for that this
is kind of like a little bit of an
assessment for you to see what areas you
have problems with okay some of these
don't apply ok stress mainly you want to
get a list of all the people you know
that stress you out and avoid them for a
while you want to avoid the news you
want to avoid stressful situations you
want to do certain activities I
recommend an acupressure for your body
to pull stress out you wanna do
everything you can do to enhance the
reduction of stress because cortisol is
triggered and cortisol will stop your
weight loss so I will put some links
down below
alright msg what is that monosodium
glutamate that's in a lot of foods start
looking at the labels it's in oh my gosh
it's in even cottage cheese that's
unless it's organic it's in all the
fast-food restaurants I mean all their
foods it's in Chinese foods but it's
hidden as modified food starch okay I
got I'll put a video down there at very
important restaurant foods you don't
know what you're getting it's a
crapshoot there's so many things they
put in that food that you have no idea
and primarily hidden sugars msg to make
it taste better but inevitably people go
out to dinner way too much
and that is what's keeping him from
losing weight not to mention where do
they bring you they bring you bread they
bring you dessert they bring you alcohol
okay so it's really difficult to do this
when you're going to restaurants next
one is a avoid overtraining
if you're at a bootcamp or you're
working out too hard and you're not
recovering and you're not sleeping
you're not going to lose weight you're
gonna lose muscle mass so this is very
very important especially when you start
out because you're not used to it last
thing is constipation I have people that
don't even go like maybe they go once a
week or once every two weeks that is a
serious constipation problem and that is
going to stop your weight loss again I
have a lot of videos on getting to the
root cause of that okay
I'll put them down below so I just kind
of summarize all the things that you
need to look at in order to lose your
stomach it's comprehensive now you have
the video as a checklist go ahead and
apply this and put your comments below
thanks for so much for watching